now all right so in case you forgot
thanksgiving is a week from today taking
a live look at mccarran airport tonight
as they prepare for what's going to be
really busy holiday season yes and as
health restrictions roll back vaccine
become more accessible airport officials
are encouraging travelers plan ahead
before getting on your plane hopefully
i'll be able to leave out on monday
hopefully the parking and the bookings
aren't too bad thelma dotson just
relocated to las vegas she's a frequent
flyer but her traveling skills will be
put to the test next week i think it's
laid out well you have the passenger
pick up you can go right here right into
short term
it's dedicated to that specifically so
you're not caught up into all of the
other traffic
aaa's holiday forecast expects more than
53 million people to travel this year
between november 24th and the 28th over
the past few months mccarran officials
say terminal 1 parking has been almost
at capacity on weekends their advice
plan ahead we expect thanksgiving to be
more of the same and so we really want
those people
the locals who are choosing to travel
for thanksgiving to know
what to look for and be prepared when
this parking structure is filled drivers
will be directed to terminal 3 long-term
garage remember there is also the
economy lot with courtesy shuttle
service if you're planning to park here
we are recommending that you give
yourself at least another 60 minutes
parking fees according to airport
officials will be enforced remember ride
share apps can save you time for a
couple of bucks everybody is ready to
get out and enjoy the holidays and get
back with their family christian casa is
live local now that was eight news now
anchor christian koskaris reporting
airport officials say it's never too
early to start planning check out
8newsnow.com for more tips and resources
for your holiday travels